now up to 23 two more than Brock Bess here's
a shot by Kevin stanland and a sharp right
Pat saved by Demco stopped the rebound attempt
as well took the kulakov bid in the chest but
that first stop off St stenland was a Dandy
job up is that they added players that play
to an identity that they have there's kachuck
behind the net he finds Kevin stenin who was
signed as a free agent at 245 starts at Rogers
Arena here's eblad with a shot blocker Sav by
Demco Reinhardt tips the puck down the boards
pson blocks that now he's in a battle for the
puck with Reinhardt barov digs it free works
it to Evan Rodriguez now barov Cuts in front
of the back hand chips the puck through the slot
and into the near Corner picks it up there plays
a little give and go but now Patterson gets in
the way intercepts and Carries ahead to Center
Le Pon dumps one across laferty wrist one wide
of the goal Pon gets the puck quickly back to
aor up long shot CH ly got a stick on it but it
went wide at the goal Rodriguez clears the puck
to Center Myers missed it and here's Reinhardt
across the barov the Florida Captain with a shot
that sailed over top of the goal pu picked up
behind the N mck got around one man then lost
the puck to lomberg held in at the right Point
by mour who threw one on goal Tyler Myers takes
the puck from behind the net dumps one ahead to
Center loina one hands it to the side here's Nick
cousins on the backand centering the puck and
intercepting was Teddy bler TS one ahead Darin
just won't be able to catch up he was behind Mika
would have had a beine to the net had he been able
to catch up to that pocket center now here's bler
to Garland in the corner P the Blue Line Ian Cole
Noah Json long R shot wide of the goal puck comes
off the end Chuck G sto by the right P this play
starts earlier where Conor Garland's going to
get this puck in the back back D bosi gets AC
cross just couldn't flip it over the pad of bosi
who was able to kick it out and kick the game
scoreless darland now fights to the
Pucket the Florida Blue Lun kicks
it free for kiso makes a move cuts it on goal he
scores gos and back to back games for Andre kusco
who had a thank you point for Conor Garland after
that one strong right had say but look at the
effort here as the play continues Garland keeps
the Play Alive kzo straight Off the Bench
goal scores score once they start to feel
it the puck starts to go in the net the play by
Garland creates the chance kachuck gets the loose
Puck sets up shop on the left wing dises one
down to the goal line here's Bennett putting
one in front Veri stopped by Demco Veri didn't
get his a shot there sends the puck in off the
Stick of Mika moves to try to time up along
the boards barov cble the puck hoglander gets
it in behind to JT Miller bounces off that
check C ra up onour lost his helmet a good
four check shift his besser in on the chip
and Chase and when barov burps the puck up
a little bit that's pretty uncharacteristic
of him now mour is going to run into Miller
Miller reverses on him and that's a much bigger
man that Jon takes his pass and dumps the puck
in behind the Florida goal barasi out his net
bad pass for Mika Kut look to take advantage
with a sharp angle backhander couldn't get it to
go in the midst of happening makes a weak pass
picked off by hoglander dropped pass to Miller
JC Miller finds quenn Hughes shot sticks save
Le Browski and he'll reach out and grab the
puck I think the media was all happy about
it here's barov skating through Center gets
in over the line with a shot stick saved by
Den eats had three different defense pairs on
the shift as a shot is stopped and chopped on
goal again deno's got it as I get to the bottom
of why they're mixing up their parents like
a natural Encyclopedia Brown up here yeah
you're chance for Joshua scores on his own
rebound spinning backhander wouldn't go but the
Chip Shot on the second attempt sure did and it's
two nothing pretty similar with it binus doesn't
get this poac out both canak goals have been where
they didn't get the poac out of the zone and when
Eckman Larson can't clear it Joshua stays with it
the first sa is a nice one by fosi and that
sweet little finish there by Dakota Reinhard
moves in after Lees for Rodriguez back to Mika
rot tipped and Demco able to make the save and
forsing carries the other away for the Panthers
Bo St forsland trying to get away from kzco dises
one across Bennett's open he shoots off the M
of D who came out the challenge and make that
sack the Miller line back out hoglander hustles
into the loose P puts it behind the goal Miller's
got some room centers Brock besser loads up and a
blocker save by lovi Panthers steal the puck back
here's eclad with room makes a move shoots them
to the save rebound B is RO by the left half of
sper death what a save there as barov looked to
have a GI me what a great stop here as the puck
bounces off him and kachuk is going to take
it to his backend but barkov's right there he
just trying to go across to zorov could chuck
is there to take the puck off the board in the
middle for kulakov he relays to veren that
was a close play to the line here's a drop
pass Bennett with a shot play penalty out again K
went between the legs so blue line leads to this
turnover and the Panthers are able to rush up
the ice you look at the teams that the conuts
are ahead of and you can almost say okay well
they're 12 points up of them but really it's 13
because such a big gap in regulation wins with
almost everyone remember a couple of years ago
when Florida took their big jump forward
and they had I believe 2 turnover Joshua
scores that's not your fault Ray that's bossk's
it's three nothing and Dakota
Joshua has his second of the
game barosi comes out to play this and it's almost
like he doesn't see Joshua there I mean he put it
great on the tape as Joshua skates to the area
he's supposed to be when doesn't go behind the
net he stops so he's not too deep in a two goal
game thank you very much Joshua a freebie and
it's three nothing 2 second to go in the two-man
Advantage Quinn Hughes Miller Pon shoots off the
mask as moski slid to his left and took that one
off the nogget here's Miller b h the PO on his own
rebound 22nd of the year for Brock fesser they
retrieve the puck and start working it around
this is where the penalty Killers run out of
gas they don't miss this time although it takes
two chances as fesser hits the post finds the
puck before bosi can get back to it oh it hit
bosi as well post bosi besser 22 a power play
goal and it's four nothing defenseman is lson
they ran into each other here's gler shanding he's
already got one this year Ted gler on goal stop by
neas had the only other five on three
goal for the Canucks this year before
to one tonight there's a shot at
the post as he beats star and throw
it on the the tape for you there's
the result the 92 mph shot off the
pipe kachuck pass blocked by Myers Matthew
kachuck gets it again feeds Bennett in front
Veri is stopped by Demco track that puck as it
was sent in front and Demco the save on Carter
verh and poring able to get there first and
play it away from the conut forward pass get
sud Rodriguez heing with a shot off the shoulder
the N Go stops some Friendly Fire as it came off
jwon trying to break things up thrown back to the
blue line binus thrs one on goal blocker saved in
the KF clears and that'll do it that's a 36 save
shut out third of the Season sixth of his career